non mais mais ça fait plaisir vous soyez
la paix vous savez que vous êtes
extrêmement séduisant en eau
non mais je vous jure isabelle rien
l'habille ah oui moi je trouve très bon
mais j'ai enseigné jusqu'à consommer
n'est pas permis aux lions à pompe
c'est pour marianne pourquoi quartier
d'adjamé à part au pied si j'ai rien
compris la même île et un oignon baril
va alors il a uriné au pied
j'ai compris vous prévoyez une émission
parallèle à bas régime
cette fois ci votre propre émission ça
fait plaisir
non mais là elle ça fait quatre jours
qu'elle a pas dormi aussi aller au bout
du rouleau la salle et quand on commence
à y voir une façon là c'est une horreur
l'otan dit recchi brad boyes et tuera il
un sourire faute de sting celle de miss
laurent spirituel l'indéniable nouvelle
oui merci salut je sors je vous étiez
encore là